forza ragazzi e benvenuti a persona ha
bisogno di paint ciao red che in
italiano significa dipingi la città di
rosso e quel rosso non è che ci ha detto
che avrei fatto altri episodi perché
dall ultimo ho riscoperto la la
genialità di questo gioco quindi ho
scaricato altri livelli però il per
adesso è solo nero a ecco mi sembra
strano salve giorno 2
ok ok ok mi sa è che cacchio succede qua
cosa state facendo
cos'è sta roba a giudicare dal tuo
sguardo sta roba da un po di galera
assuefazioni non scherzo non sono bravo
a recitare va bene prevedere come sta
roba perché non capisco in realtà dove
sono le armi qua c'è una chiave per sé
top pick up chi addirittura puoi
sbloccarti delle porte delle zone chiuse
con le porte questa roba c'è un livello
incredibile questo va bene e mi spiace
prima di iniziare a larissa do
un'occhiata in giro
prendo questo non girarti male salve
giorno buongiorno
cos'è qua vivendo tutti belli incazzati
però ancora nessuno mi rompe le balle
anzi prendo questo grazie mi piace molto
di più come ragazzi allora torniamo
semplicemente qualche ho visto che c'è
una nave incastrata vedo solo se qua si
può usare la chiave se non si usa quad e
meno tutti più riarmi qua bellissimo
fichera ho visto il serbatoio di armi
stiamo 41 tutto a posto
madara ma sta male immaginano molto più
forte
a porco demonio sei tu che sei
imbattibile
com'è possibile ho beccato un unico tipo
imbattibile di tutta la mappa o staff
usa non me lo spiego parco lemonia non
sia un peccato solo lui era invincibile
gli ho tirato ottomana in bocca è il
cane nicchia che botte ragazzi suo
livello è veramente difficile perché la
gente non va giù ma non ha neanche più
la faccia possono fare e mori ok ragazzi
sta finendo veramente nel trash sto
casino è ve lo dico perché secondo
meglio l'acqua non ci esco vivo però fa
niente becca di la tazza da te io questo
quadro lo posso battere troppo grosso
aiuto aiuto
oddio questo sei proiettili a bari mario
mori e che cacchio quanto devo farti beh
beh non è possibile non va giù sono
l'ammazzo adesso non ammazzo più regale
impossibile non tutto a posto
prendo il tuo scettro in prestito un
attimo esclusa nei pro mi serve perché
grosso e teoricamente potrei fargli a
che male donna per farmi sta facendo
fuori ed è un nardò
dopo le prima come è possibile raga sono
praticamente morto perché mi basta uno
sputo e sono per terra quindi non ce la
farò mai però nel dubbio proviamoci
meno male ragazze posto sono morto sono
morto sono marco san marcos 91 4 profiti
chi lo stesso non devo farmi toccare
neanche per sbaglio perché a me questa è
spam
volevo fare questa è spartano mi è
riuscito ci sono 50 nemici sono arrivato
a 25 bob una cagata rifacciamo comunque
quelli questa e sparta secondo me lo
devo fare subito e la partenza
proviamoci
nel cloud a posto
questa è spartacus se l'avessi preso in
pieno del 30 la juventus andrà a giocare
salve devo stare attento perché se mi
colpite per un sacco di vita e non me lo
posso permettere
per essere hanno fatti fuori quattro in
totale ne devo fare quei 50 impossibile
buongiorno eroe
ti ho salvato la vita no ti ho salvato
maledizione ma anche una riconoscenza ma
se vi ho salvato la vita che volete
hyatt sta arrivando qualcuno là dietro
99 sono a cagà l'hack è male porco
demonio quanto mi leva aiuto shockwave
aerei disastro parte
se effettivamente morto qualcuno a parte
questo porca vacca scusami non volevamo
ferirti e reichen in mezzo non posso
farci niente
non è morto nessuno ma perché lo scià
quelli sposta solo la gente la prega
ammazza giustamente associando tutti con
me perfetto ottima ottima soluzione che
ho trovato non seguitemi mai nelle liste
devo capire se con questo riesco a far
fuori il tipo gigante perché vuole
importante quello fa fuori veramente
dove è morto è molto complicata possa
quanto sei in piedi tutti ragazzi sto
facendo un miliardo di action
questa è veramente è stata una gran
giocata per la prima che c'è quello
gigante che sta esattamente qui sotto
quindi morirò tantissimo il suo stato
incredibilmente occhio quello gigante
c'è sempre mio amico di prima tra
l'altro che è circondato solo che
riuscirà a salvarla veramente un cadetto
sai cosa mi conviene fare mi conviene
non aspettare lo shock wave e usare
l'ultimo potere per far carico di sulla
barca perché se non ha veramente un
casino ti ho salvato il culo amico mio
mi devi la vita anche se ti colpisce a
posto insediata scusami non volevo ho
sbagliato passaggi al mio amico però non
mi e non mi e non è subito contro e
poiché sta dicendo magari ecco infatti
vedi non lo ricolfi toe magari si è
sbagliato ha detto bravo che sei saggio
fammi fuori i giganti vado a far fuori
questi mamma tutto a posto
pagan che cattiveria che c'è in questo
momento ne vedeva con le mani mori non è
un sorgente dietro effetto bravo bravo
mentre tutti gli altri brevissimo meno
male che non va cagato questo va sotto
ci sentiamo sotto fanno fuori tumori
freddo potevi delle armi da temi delle
armi a posto eccoci 1 i boss
ci siamo quasi era gallo smythe devo
usarlo tantissimo per far fuori tutti in
realtà
[Musica]
maledizione gravami condividerle ma lo
smart ready prova a farti fuori questo
che gigante che ho provato a colpirlo ma
mi sa che ha un sacco di vita lo zio
ok
bravo ami contro questo qualche grosso
tu chi sei combattendosi ancora questo
che in piedi ho fatto io dai dai dai dai
farmi fuori l'altro facendola per
votarlo smythe ragalo smythe è
difficilissimo e lo devono usare contro
quelli di per forza perché questi quasi
del mondo imbattibili smythe medi
vado quest'anno smart drug a 12 e poi
soprattutto quello con lui impassibile
ci ho messo un miliardo di proiettili
prima per farlo fuori perfetto ora devo
continuare a bersagliarlo perché se non
riesco mai del lanciato otto miliardi di
proiettili sarà servito
vediamo
ma il re making un po è servito però non
è morto e la cosa mi dà troppo fastidio
allora ma il re mening madonna è
invincibile maledizione
togliti che culo allora se il mio
compagno distrae tutti io faccio fuori
quelli rimanenti
e poi ci piazza un bel set parte berserk
pazzesco quelli che sono al bordeaux ti
faccio cadere tutto e lunghi capelli
mentre madonna che rischio madonna del
rischio 5 remaining spiega rimasto il
gigante e molto il mio amico è
fortissimo ha fatto fuori anche gigante
5 reining una mano io non volevo colpire
te scusa 4 ore mining vai a chiamare
bravo grazie
ok tra le macchie rimasto che i must
scusami grassi in tre di cui 16 tubi di
ti devo ammazzare però ti ammazzo alla
fine sono è un problema sono rimasti
c'è qualcuno che è rimasto vivo eccolo
lì
1 st là sopra lo vedo è uno l'abbiamo
trovato uno è mio amico e l'altro mese
che ce lo trovo da solo due romeni
mi dispiace rega lo so che non volevate
questa questo finale ma oggi lieto fine
dai raga dure mining porco demonio
picchio el'altro
perfetto l'ho colpito meno male perché
ogni per ogni arma la sua area
dinamicità quindi non sapevo come tarare
il lancio ma ce l'ho fatta e ne manca
uno che non so dove sia
manca solo un tizio se non è qualcuno
che è rimasto bloccato da qualche parte
di sé scusare kings cross ma ok è
qualcuno che è rimasto bloccato qualche
parte come ci gioco quello che volete
adesso della draga è rimasta una persona
e non la trovo ril giurano incredibile
49 su 50 laddove è chi è rimasto vivo
che non vedono marca vacca sono io
no no va bene non conta anche neanche
mezzo d'olio
mi piace poi
il sopra schifo
che questo faccia un po di convulsioni
non è che è vivo è semplicemente randon
lantern
no è morto nome non c'è
sono caduto sono vivo come c'era una
roccia che sfruttava euro sono morto non
posso più di salire a meno che io non
vedo in questo momento il tizio sono
morto perché non ho più modo di risalire
cacchio sono caduto che stupido tuoi 6 6
pazienza 49 50 la ka mi spiace che non
ho trovato lui a chiedermi dove fosse
gli sia piaciuto questa raffinata un rap
farò un altro episodio sicuro perché
ucciso altri livelli incredibili
iscriviti al canale si chiede se vi
piace e non ai ragazzi come sempre ci
vediamo la prossima scazzottata family
friendly da ragazzi
[Musica]